Mother's Day is right around the corner
and what better way to show Mom you love
her than with flowers call 555 flower
and for just 29.95 get this beautiful
spring bouquet mom will love the vibrant
colors 555 flower is not a real phone
number it's too short
phone number needs to be 10 digits long
to work 555 flower is only nine digits
long so it will not work or what about
this gorgeous tulip arrangement for just
3995 555 flower sounds like a real phone
number especially when you say it fast
five by five flower see that way when
you tell mom that you really wanted to
buy her flowers so you call it five five
five flower but you couldn't get through
she'll believe you then if she tries to
call five five five flower and can't get
through you can just say well you must
have screwed up somehow mom forget it
just forget the whole damn thing got off
my back call that and we'll throw in I
don't know a million rubies and erase
books give your mother what she deserves
[Music]
you
you